anarchie pour évacuer dans l'urgence le
plus possible d'étrangers d'afghans qui
veulent fuir l'afghanistan avant le 31
août date limite fixée par les talibans
pour le départ des forces américaines
étaient dix banques lui met en garde les
états unis contre le maintien envisagé
de leur force au delà de ce délai un
garde à vous devant a été tué ce matin
dans une fusillade entre forces de
sécurité et des assaillants non
identifiés
la rentrée scolaire approche et elle
s'annonce comme la priorité du
gouvernement nouveau protocole sanitaire
afin d'éviter les contaminations sur les
bancs de l'école et notamment un
excellent avec six nations facilité mais
cela fait débat la rentrée devrait aussi
être marquée par le retour des sujets
sociaux tels que la réforme des
retraites ou encore celle de l'assurance
chômage
en tunisie des forces de sécurité du
pays sont postés devant le parlement
auprès de la capitale le pays est
suspendu à la décision de son président
le délai de 30 jours après le gel du
parlement par cas ici enfin aujourd'hui
ce dernier le choix de prolonger ou non
cette période d'exception destinée selon
lui à lutter contre la corruption les
précisions en ce moment
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez
toujours un climat de tension extrême en
afghanistan notamment à l'aéroport de
kaboul où une course contre la montre
s'est engagée pour évacuer ceux qui
craignent les représailles des talibans
un garde afghan a été tué et trois
personnes blessées ce matin après des
chemins des échanges de tirs entre
soldats américains et allemands avec
face à eux des assaillants non
identifiés
le retrait des troupes américaines censé
prendre fin le 31 août est lui remis en
question joe biden évoque des
discussions en cours côté américain mais
les talibans eux préviennent ils
n'annonceront pas de gouvernement tant
que des troupes ne seront pas partis où
elle vit de bennani avec max qui va
faire
c'est une prise de parole aux allures
presque de rétropédalage le président
biden questionné sur la présence des
forces américaines
des discussions sont en cours entre nous
et les militaires au sujet de la
prolongation notre espoir est que nous
n'aurons pas à prolonger mais il va y
avoir des discussions
je suppose sur l'état d'avancement du
processus des en définitive si nous ne
quittons pas l'afghanistan maintenant
quand le ferons nous encore dix ans
encore cinq ans encore un an je ne suis
pas prêt à envoyer votre fils ou votre
fille se battre en afghanistan
des forces américaines censé se retirer
totalement du pays le 31 août les
talibans ont prévenu de conséquences si
les états unis retarder leur départ
la position du gouvernement de joe biden
et elle critiqué ces dernières heures
par son prédécesseur à la maison blanche
il a livré notre base aérienne il a
livré nos armes il a livré notre
ambassade on a dépensé un milliard de
dollars pour construire cette ambassade
hallucinante et il a abandonné le cher
citoyen américain ils sont livrés à eux
mêmes ils ne se rendent pas compte quand
j'étais président nous n'avions que de
la force
la maison blanche a informé que plus de
trente mille personnes ont été évacuées
depuis le 14 août à bord d'avions
militaires américains et de pays alliés
une immense opération d'évacuation qui
sera au coeur des négociations lors
d'une réunion cruciale du g7 ce mardi
présidée par la grande bretagne annonce
faite sur twitter par le premier
ministre britannique boris johnson en
déplacement samedi en espagne au chevet
des réfugiés
la présidente de la commission
européenne a appelé les plus grands
leaders du monde à faire preuve de
responsabilité
du côté de moscou vladimir poutine a
assuré que la russie en étroite
collaboration avec ses partenaires
occidentaux ferait tout pour assurer la
stabilité en afghanistan la question de
la sécurité est également soulevée par
le président russe qui dit d'être
attentif aux centaines de milliers de
personnes qui pourraient fuir le pays
avec la crainte de combattants déguisé
en réfugiés
joe biden ont misé âge maintien des
troupes américaines au delà du 31 août
mais les talibans mettant en garde les
américains emmanuel dupuis président
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe évoque lui effectivement les
nombreux risques courus par
cet appel a peu de chances d'être
acceptée par les talibans puisque ces
mêmes talibans ont d'ores et déjà dit
qu'il n'était absolument pas question
les talibans sont déjà en train
d'accuser des américains d'être
responsable de ce fiasco et je pense
très sincèrement que si les états unis
prolongent ne serait ce que de quelques
jours il peut y avoir des provocations
pour ne pas dire des tentatives de saper
modus vivendi ou le statu quo qui
consiste à ce que les américains aient
négocié mal mais néanmoins négocier le
retrait de leurs troupes dernier élément
aussi les américains restent plus
longtemps il s'expose encore davantage à
un autre risque est celui des attentats
mais n'est pas forcément pas les
talibans mais par leur ennemi commun les
thalys a bigger azam donc l'état
islamique présents en afghanistan qui
combat autant les forces occidentales
autant le gouvernement afghan déchu que
les talibans désormais au pouvoir et
malgré tout la france elle estime
nécessaire un délai supplémentaire au
delà du 31 août pour mener à bien les
évacuations la france qui poursuit
justement de nouvelles évacuations via
les émirats arabes unis deux mille
personnes ont été exfiltrés de kaboul
par les équipes françaises sur place
parmi eux une centaine de français des
afghans situations jugées à risque
annonce du ministre français des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
sur place à abou dhabi
discussion que nous avons eue tout à
l'heure avec notre équipe à kaboul
montre la l'extrême difficulté de la
situation ça n'a pas empêché
le fait que l'on a pu exfiltré 2000
personnes 90 français
les autres sont soit des agents locaux
qui ont travaillé pour nous un petit
monde parce que beaucoup avaient déjà
été évacués avant soit des auxiliaires
de défense c'est qu'ils avaient été
aussi en grande partie évacuée avant
mais certains ont voulu revenir plus
plus vite et puis essentiellement des
afghans qui sont en risque en difficulté
de par leur engagement qui nous ont été
recommandé par leur propre histoire leur
propre volonté et qu'il importe que la
france assure le devoir moral de les
exfiltrer
la résolution du conflit en crimée objet
d'un forum international à kiev en
ukraine sur place les représentants
d'une cinquantaine de pays participent
une initiative dénoncée par la russie
les précisions de notre correspondante à
moscou vera goffman
la russie n'a rien à voir avec les
partis engagés dans le conflit à l'est
de l'ukraine a affirmé le porte parole
du kremlin dmitri peskov rjc ainsi à la
déclaration de la chancelière allemande
angela merkel qui avait accusé la russie
d'être engagés dans le conflit dans le
donbass je vous propose d'écouter
nos opinions divergent ici de plus ce ne
sont pas que des opinions il faudrait
rappeler ce qui est une pierre angulaire
de tout ce processus du règlement de la
crise en ukraine les accords de minsk
la russie n'est même pas cité dans les
accords de minsk il cite les parties en
conflit et la russie n'a rien à voir
avec les parties du conflit il ne faudra
donc pas dire des choses non fondées il
faut toujours se référer à ces accords
ils définissent clairement les parties
des conflits
dans ce sens nous ne sommes pas d'accord
en ce qui concerne le sommet du format
normandie puis veulent tenir ce sommet
de manière à ce que cela devienne une
étape importante du règlement à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine
n'ont qu'à mieux pour tenir un sommet il
faut un contenu substantiel qui n'est
toujours pas là
une déclaration qui intervient donc à la
suite du forum international sur les
crimes est organisée ce lundi à qui est
ce sont les représentants il quand tu
aimes deux pays qui se sont réunis pour
l'occasion considérant tous que le
rattachement de la crimée à la russie en
2014 à la suite du référendum correspond
à une annexion la russie selon dmitri
peskov considère cette rencontre comme
extrêmement hostile envers le pays et
anti-russe il a également souligné que
la russie n'acceptez pas ces allégations
à l'égard de cette région russe
en france le conseil des ministres fait
sa rentrée mercredi à l'elysée priorité
sera donnée au sujet de la crise
sanitaire avec la lutte contre le coc
u19 notamment à l'école puisque la
rentrée scolaire a lieu dans dix jours
les grandes réformes sociales seront
aussi évoqués maxime hébert
une rentrée d'action et de résultats
objectifs fixés par emmanuel macron pour
son retour de vacances premier conseil
de défense de la rentrée ce mercredi est
une priorité qui n'a toujours pas changé
la lutte contre le coc vivent 19 avec
70% de primo vaccinées en france paris a
accéléré sa campagne de vaccination cet
été mais reste sous la menace du variant
delta dans ce contexte le premier vrai
chantier pour l'exécutif c'est la
rentrée scolaire du 2 septembre prochain
parmi les annonces de jean michel
blanquer r
l'accès au vaccin directement dans les
collèges et les lycées pas de quoi
rassurer professionnels de la santé et
de l'éducation
inquiet pour les plus jeunes élèves les
alertes se multiplient partout dans le
monde aux etats-unis au canada en inde
au royaume uni en italie en espagne
les pédiatres et les sociétés savantes
appelle à protéger davantage les moins
de 12 ans à notre tour aujourd'hui de
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé il nous
apparaît aujourd'hui impensable pour la
majorité des départements français
d'envisager une reprise au niveau 2 du
protocole sanitaire alors que le taux
d'incidents chez les 0 19 ans est cinq
fois supérieur à celui de la rentrée
rentrée scolaire rentrée sociale aussi
le plan de relance de 100 milliards
d'euros est en cours d'application et le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
planche déjà sur un nouveau plan
d'investissement
syndicats des salariés et du patronat
seront reçues les 1er et 2 septembre
prochain pour un tour complet des sujets
sociaux un abandon de la réforme des
retraites est évoquée est une nouvelle
priorité la réforme de l'allocation
chômage prévue le 1er octobre prochain
est elle aussi très controversé beauvau
de la sécurité en septembre agenda
international de ces prochains jours
emmanuel macron devra enfin composer
avec les questions de sécurité et
d'immigration avant l'élection le
président français régulièrement accusés
de courtiser l'électorat de droite a de
nouveau subi les critiques après ses
propos sur les réfugiés afghans à huit
mois de la présidentielle
l'huile qui souhaitaient une rentrée
offensive marchera sur des oeufs kit
peut-être à ont cassé
pour en parler de cette rentrée nous
sommes avec arno fabre administrateur
national du collectif les styles en
rouge bonsoir merci avec nous en direct
sur rtl france alors beaucoup dans le
milieu de l'éducation a pris ce
protocole annoncé par jean michel
blanquer dans la presse un précisément
dans le jdd dimanche est ce que c'est
c'est votre cas aussi ça veut dire qu'il
n'y a pas eu de consultation
ah non tout à fait il n'y a pas eu de
consultation et il n'y a eu au mieux que
quelques informations envoyées aux
organisations professionnelles
organisations syndicales et
effectivement le billet le plus fréquent
pour jean michel blanquer c'est de
communiquer via la presse alors le jdd
surtout en ligne dans la partie réservée
aux abonnés bon pour communiquer avec
les 1 million 200 mille personnel qui
travaille dans l'éducation nationale
plus les familles des 13 millions
d'élèves je trouve que vraiment c'est
prendre cette rentrée la légère et
surtout pour la plupart un des
professeurs c'est une rentrée qui va se
faire sous le signe malheureusement de
la résignation pourquoi parce que cette
rentrée en fait elle se fait que c'est
la deuxième rentrée avec le co lead et
ça sera la troisième année scolaire
concerné par le cos vide et encore une
fois nous sommes dans une improvisation
dans une impréparation totale
tout simplement parce que de toute façon
on le sait jean michel blanquer est
vraiment l'homme du déni 1 c'est le
petit bol sonar aux français celui pour
qui finalement balleux qu'ovide c'est
quelque chose qui doit rapidement passé
1 et surtout pour qu'on reprenne les
choses comme si rien ne s'était produit
un on ne va surtout pas changer 1 ce qui
se passe dans les classes où nous
demandons de goran changement et c'est
maintenant qu'il faut lui alors
effectivement un protocole retenu pour
la rentrée on nous dit que c'est celui
du niveau de cours en présentiel
notamment dans les écoles collèges et
lycées masque obligatoire à l'intérieur
dès la primaire limitation du brassage
par niveau et aération renforcée c'est
vrai qu'il ya pas un changement majeur
vous espériez plus
c'est pour ça que je parlais de
résignation je crois que la plupart nos
collègues espérait surtout une prise de
conscience une prise de conscience du
fait que enfants le ministre de
l'éducation mais aussi bien sur les plus
hautes autorités de l'état c'est à dire
monsieur macro le président de la
république avec est aidé par son conseil
scientifique se rend compte que oui
l'école est un véritable lieu de
contamination ce sont des choses que
l'on sait sont des choses qui sont
établis scientifiquement
or malheureusement c'est justement cet
écart entre bien sûr les annonces et la
réalité mais cet écart surtout entre la
réalité scientifique est ce que les
solutions qui sont proposées regarder on
nous propose un seul niveau le niveau 2
pour l'ensemble dû territoire
métropolitain
c'est complètement absurde haut depuis
la crise le début de la crise du copine
à de nombreuses reprises les décisions
étaient territorialise les niveaux d'
alerte et les décisions c'est-à-dire et
ouvertures de classes notamment après le
premier grand confinement ont été faites
en ce sens donc encore une fois je crois
que là il faut absolument des choses
simples à mettre en place mais qui
nécessite aussi des moyens et des moyens
vous parliez tout à l'heure dans le
précédent reportage d'une politique de
relance par l'investissement
l'école est la grande oubliée de cet
investissement il fallait le faire au
niveau des postes pourquoi parce qu'il
faut dédoubler les classes c'est à dire
des doubles et c'est à dire faire des
2000 groupe aux phares ronds charge tous
les élèves concernant vraiment ce
protocole sanitaire jean michel blanquer
vous le savez a écarté un ce concours au
pass sanitaires pour les professeurs les
élèves et les parents d'élèves vous vous
auriez souhaité qu'ils instaurent
c'était cet esprit table justement dans
ce contexte à risque que vous nous
décrivez
ce qui est souhaitable surtout c'est de
prendre le risque tel qu'il est
actuellement on le sait liv ce fameux
variant delta contamine essentiellement
les jeunes et comme mon ex et on l'a
entendu à de nombreuses reprises la
nature a horreur du vide elle va vers
ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés c'est à
dire vers les enfants à partir de là il
fallait absolument que on met en place
tout de suite notamment des capteurs de
co2 tout simplement pour prendre on peut
dire la température du risque mais là
sans jouer sur les mots ça sera un gros
risque pour le ministre de se rendre
compte que scientifiquement et bien dans
les classes les contaminations ont lieu
il fallait aussi des purificateurs d'air
alors ça effectivement ça coûte cher
cette mutation c1 c'est non non non pas
du tout non non non pas du tout les
capteurs de co2 ont été recommandées
mais il n'y a pas les financements elle
contrairement à nous dit on bon oui mais
alors justement qu'est-ce qu'un une
aération renforce on va éviter
d'endetter
normal prononcer et bien c'est ça que
vous propose jean michel blanquer donc à
un moment donné je crois que des données
scientifiquement établie il faut que les
ars en voit dans les 400 à 500 mille
salles de classe des gens vraiment
rapidement pour prendre la mesure du
risque à partir de là voir si l'aération
peut se faire s'il ne peut pas se faire
il faut mettre en place immédiatement en
fonction aussi du taux d'incidence est
bien il faut mettre en place les deux
mines groupe pour parce que c'est
faisable parce que c'est souhaitable et
parce que sinon il y aura comme
l'institut pasteur le prédit un de
manière la scientifique ce ne sont pas
des maj 1 ce ne sont pas des diseuses de
bonne aventure et l'institut pasteur
prédit 50000 contamination par jour chez
les jeunes dès la mi ou la fin septembre
il faut donc empêché absolument une
cinquième bague pour ça il faut soit
changé de ministre sans que le ministre
ma dernière question à nos femmes pas la
moindre puisque jean michel blanquer a
annoncé
elle
une campagne de vaccination débutera dès
la rentrée scolaire pour les élèves de
plus de 12 ans qui le souhaitent on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de doutes de
réticences et les parents même si plus
de 55 % des adolescents sont déjà
vaccinés d'une dose vous comprenez ses
parents ou au contraire il faut
justement renforcer ses campagnes de
vaccination est allé dans ce sens là
la question de la vaccination est une
question de santé publique moi je suis
professeur de français je ne me
prononcerai pas sur ces questions ce qui
est très important c'est qu'il faut
protéger les populations or comme la
plupart des contaminations étaient
kloster selon santé publique france ont
lieu dans le cadre scolaire
contrairement à ce que dit le ministre
je le répète soit il faut changer de
ministres qui se conduit comme un
imposteur soit alors il faut des
décisions fermes et notamment dans les
zones les plus contaminées le sud de la
france et l'île de france
merci à tarnos favre d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france
est toujours en france on évoque à
présent les conséquences économiques
dues aux incendies dans le sud du pays
illustration dans le département du var
à cogolin où le vigneron pierre audemar
est durement touché son domaine a
presque entièrement brûlé
reportage les appels ferrières et sur un
récit de cyrielle benabid est
le domaine de la jyske ou du moins ce
qu'il en reste
le vigneron pierre houde marc a dû
combattre les flammes dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi dernier
épaulé par les membres de sa famille ils
ont arrosé les bâtiments pour les sauver
mais malgré leurs efforts les pertes
sont énormes on a commencé avec leur
avec l'instructeur qui encore par terre
on a commencé à l'éteindre ce qu'on a pu
mais le rôle m ca prenaient les
dimensions impressionnantes sacra mais
petit à petit c'est à dire que les
poutres ont pris feu et les poutres ont
transmis aux autres poutres avec
l'isolation du père forme et donc le
chai à barriques à aboyer
chez la cuverie a volé le ch et de
conditionnement biba brûlé puis ensuite
le local de vente et qui a brûlé une
portion de ses 52 hectares de vignes est
également parti en fumée le domaine qui
travaillent les trois couleurs de vin
produit entre 120 et 130 mille
bouteilles par an avec seulement
quelques cuves de rouge restantes les
pertes financières sont lourdes
mais après avoir vécu l'enfer pierre
audemar relativise il est vivant et
déterminés à relancer l'activité avec le
soutien de sa fille mais une de mes
filles et mes une cagnotte en ligne
justement pour éventuellement s'il ya
des personnes qui peuvent nous aider
pour rattraper une partie de ses pertes
dues à la vétusté et 500 participants en
trois jours je m'y attendais pas je vous
dis la vérité je n'attendais pas mais
j'ai besoin qu'à ma fille et à passer à
ça je me sentais gêné parce que c'est
bon on te
demander ça mais si nécessaire
enfin ce qu'il faut on est solidaire
salue la famille depuis le 16e siècle
elle a connu deux guerres elle a connu
d'autres choses donc on a connu des
inondations en nappant milieu de tas de
choses
c'est pas le moment de
se laisser aller d'autres viticulteurs
ont eux aussi été touchés par l'incendié
tous gardent un objectif en tête être en
mesure de faire les vendanges qui vont
débuter d'ici une dizaine de jours mais
cette année la récolte pourrait avoir un
goût amer pour l'ensemble de la
profession on compte à peu près une
dizaine d'hectares 2 de vignes brûlés ou
saccagés et on compte 2 3 exploitations
qui ont eu des des subi des fortes
pertes et cette année on a subi beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes on ne subit le gel
on a subi la grêle est une année très
difficile pour les vignerons et pour
certains secteurs
certains cépages ont coulé aussi donc il
ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de choses cette
année
la récolte sera faible parce que on a
subi une très très forte sécheresse et
c'est pour ça qu'on est arrivé jusqu'à
ses feux
on a une petite récolte
on espère que la qualité sera l'avant il
va falloir qu'on rentre c'est ses
raisins le plus rapidement possible
les pompiers restent mobilisés en raison
des reprises provoquée par le vent
l'incendié a fait deux morts et détruit
sept mille cent hectares de forêt de
vignes et de garrigue dont près de la
moitié de la réserve nationale naturel
de la plaine des maures
en espagne à présent la justice a
tranché le couvre-feu ne sera pas
rétabli à barcelone le gouvernement
catalan on souhaitait pourtant le
prolonger malgré l'amélioration de la
situation sanitaire mais la justice
estime cela inutile et disproportionné
et précision sur place de listing là
barcelone reste sans couvre feu à la
suite d'une demande du gouvernement de
catalogne le tribunal supérieur de
justice catalan a étudié la possibilité
d'appliquer le couvre-feu dans 62
communes de la région mais la requête a
été refusée le tribunal a décidé que la
mesure s'appliquerait aux villes ayant
un taux d'incidence de 250 cas pour
100000 habitants à barcelone il est
actuellement de 97 cas pour 100000
habitants
alors il faut le rappeler que chaque
semaine depuis le 16 juillet le
gouvernement catalan demande a prolongé
le couvre feu dans une centaine de
communes de la catalogne si le tribunal
a accédé habituellement à cette demande
il a approuvé la mesure dans seulement
dix neuf communes le 19 août dernier et
barcelone en étaient exclus alors en
désaccord avec cette décision le
gouvernement catalan a formulé une
nouvelle demande afin que le couvre-feu
s'applique dans les villes de plus de 20
mille habitants ayant un taux
d'incidence de 125 cas pour 100000
habitants
mais les magistrats ont indiqué qu'une
partie des villes demandé ne
correspondait pas aux propres critères
du gouvernement catalan comme barcelone
le couvre-feu sera encore plus inutile
et disproportionné ont-ils déclaré pour
l'instant les bars et restaurants
doivent toujours fermé leurs portes à
minuit trente les responsables du
secteur réclament une ouverture jusqu'à
3 heures alors en attendant les
barcelonais à la recherche d'une
ambiance festive en baisse les rues de
la ville durant le premier week-end sans
couvre feu depuis un mois les forces de
l'ordre ont délogé plus de dix mille
personnes à barcelone
en tunisie que va décider le président
c'est aujourd'hui qui expire le délai de
30 jours depuis le gel des travaux
parlementaires
va-t-il opter pour la prolongation ou
non cette suspension du parlement la
situation politique reste tendue
d'autant que le président n'a toujours
pas nommé de nouveau gouvernement ni
dévoilé sa feuille de route les
précisions de notre correspondant à
tunis ben hassen chébili
le 25 juillet dernier le président de la
république a eu sayed surprenait tout le
monde dans les mauges en centre-
ministre mais surtout en gelant les
affaires parlementaires pour une durée
de 30 jours un délai qui touche bientôt
à sa fin tunisien association société
sils comme opposition sont sutton du jeu
relève du président de la république bat
il prolonger ce délai de 30 jours
va-t-il annoncer un gouvernement comme
ce qui est attendu ou alors va-t-il
annoncer de nouvelles réformes en
attendant le chef de l'état est seul aux
commandes il a indiqué vouloir lutter
contre la corruption il a entamé
plusieurs opérations notamment elle
c'est de la fermeture de l'instance
supérieure de la lutte contre la
corruption ces interventions se font
rares macha catalans sont ils pointent
du doigt ce qu'il appelle des mots et
les gangrènes de la société tunisienne
vendredi dernier lors d'une cérémonie de
signature de la convention de
distribution pour les aides sociales il
n'a pas manqué d'expliquer les raisons
de ce coup de force qui l'a opéré le 25
juillet et puis pour la première fois il
a pointé certains de ses ennemis à
savoir les islamistes en disant qu'il
n'avait pas peur malgré les nombreuses
menaces qu'il a reçues je vous propose
d'écouter le président ça y est comment
peuvent-ils atteindre la réputation des
hommes et des femmes il considère que
les mensonges font partie des outils
politiques
je suis au courant de ce qu'il manigance
je leur dis que je n'ai peur que de dieu
malgré leurs tentatives misérable il
pense au meurtre et aux assassinats ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'on palais
de carthage on reçoit des menaces visant
le président de la république mais cette
fois ci le ministère public a ouvert une
enquête concernant les récentes mais
reçu par le président de la république
se présentent à la public a pu pointer
les islamistes notamment le parti
ennahda parti ennahda qui n'a pas manqué
de publier sur les réseaux sociaux son
soutien au président de la république en
condamnant tout acte hostile à l'état
tunisien à la nation tunisienne bien sûr
au chef de l'état tunisien il s'est
adressé le président la république
notamment aux magistrats en disant
qu'ils devaient mieux exercer leur
travail et c'est toute impunité dans le
pays le président de la république qui
continue de mener sa barque malgré un
soutien massif de la population la
population et qui à 95% selon un sondage
sigma conseil qu'on prenne les mesures
adoptées par le président et soutiennent
le président nos populations tunisiennes
qui reste quand même suspendu aux lèvres
de kayes zayed il souhaiterait savoir
quelle feuille de route va-t-il adopter
le président va-t-il y avoir des
élections va-t-il y avoir un pépin
d'hommes quelles sont les nouvelles
réformes amorcées normalement le
président de la république devrait se
prononcer dans les jours à venir à
savoir quelles réformes va-t-il adopter
et dans lequel direction va t'il au
conduire la tunisie la tunisie qui
traverse toujours une crise économique
sociale et politique majeure et c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve dans 30 minutes
pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité
[Musique]
oui